because I wanted to hear about you
taking this week-long drive across that
was like four or five days out okay so
you said you didn't totally plan it out
to come to LA you'd been thinking about
it for a long time yeah no I've been
thinking about it since I mean in like
since I graduated high school I mean
like I've been wanting to about
therefore acting at the time and then
yeah I feel like I mean at a certain
point I was like you know what I think
I've done all I can do in New York why I
mean I was hardcore wine to pursue
filmmaking at that time and New York
just wasn't you know so theater driven
you know and I love theater I love like
Broadway and all that I love that stuff
and I want it to be like an actor on
stage for a long time but but whit as
far as like the film business I mean
like you know there's lost up at film at
the shootout there Blake you know la is
just like you know it's just a it this
is like it's like the capital of hot
it's the capital of movies you know it's
like it's just like and so I just I you
know I just thought I'd like I just I
just got to stop I just got do it you
know and and yeah I mean my it really
you know it's very I mean III I
recommend it to a lot I mean a lot
people like I like fly their cars out or
something you know I mean I I know yeah
I mean like I'd like to like Oklahoma
and like New Mexico and stay in it you
know stay you know things like really
like cheap motels and he's like weird
like you know you know all these
Scottsdale Arizona and got to like see
all these places and see real-life
drifters sorry um probably I mean it was
like it wasn't well I mean I'm sure I
mean III came across some weird people
yeah I mean just in different just
corners of the town and like it was just
but yeah I mean III definitely recommend
it I mean IIIi love the experience and
then it was a very um I mean I hated
like pulling over for gas or like
pulling over till I use the restroom
because I just love to keep moving going
and and but ya know it was it was a
really light very transcending very like
therapeutic experience cuz you know
you're just not thinking about what's
ahead of you just yet you're not you
don't think about the past at all and
it's such like in the moment kind of
thing and and yeah and it was yeah it
was great I was everyone the best
experience of my life driving out that
actually yeah I loved it was just like
totally you know you're just not
thinking about anything at that time
it's like well there's rare moments
where you just like you know there's
nothing to really hardcore
think about just yet like in that in
that very tiny amount of time and you're
just sort of like going moment to moment
and and then any move to LA and then
you're like oh god now I gotta like get
back to them you know reality you know
and and then it gets like gruesome but
but like that yeah but like that that
that brief amount of time was great
you know I loved it no were there things
leading up to that moment when you said
okay I think now is the time you were 24
yeah I think make I think making that
short probably and then like then when I
got I think I never I was thinking about
I was like am I gonna should i not make
this short and just moved out to LA
blindly or should I wait a few more
months make this short and then that's
how I and though I've had that felt like
the best about to do something like that
because I don't want to go out there
with literally nothing and so I just
like may the shore and and and then you
know we screened it at this place called
the producers Club in New York City
which is like on 44th Street it's like a
little black box they do allow like
rehearsals and plays there and but they
also do some like screenings and like
they like a projector that you can get
and you know like I mean like 70 people
came to it so it was really you know
it's a nice little turnout for that and
like they responded to it very well and
so is it like that kind of boosted up
your confidence and then you go to LA
and you're all your confidence interval
is just shattered with every day when
every ever every day brutal but like I
mean but yeah I mean like it was yeah I
mean III yeah I think I think yeah I
think was good to have like that short
film like in the in my back pocket
because that helped me like meet other
people for later for other shorts and
that they like they could take me
somewhat seriously that I did I you know
but I'm not a total idiot that I can
make movies no and and then I just
started to make more and more shorts
with more people that I was meeting out
here and you know just honing the craft
and and and and
you know just about the nuts and bolts
of movies and you know yeah
was there a moment that you thought
about turning the car around um no no it
was it was a pretty like it is pretty
like just like straight shoot just like
this is no turning back I mean like it's
like I just I don't know I mean I just I
was just in that point of my lab where's
like there's nothing there's there's
nothing more for me to do out in New
York I mean there's just like nothing
like I know what I want to do right now
like I know this new path I want to take
and New York's just not gonna do it for
me you know and and if I if I'm serious
about this I'm serious about pursuing
directing and wanting to be a writer
director than I've been I have to I have
to make the Los Angeles and I murdered
the first well the first things I went
to when I'm about to LA I wanted like
the screening of slitter which was like
a James James Gunn's movie like one of
his like early man they played it I went
to the arrow theater was the first time
I went there and James guy was there for
a Q&A the first thing that came out his
mouth was like you have to move to Los
Angeles and I was like well it's been
validated now I feel now I feel good
about this but ya know I mean like yeah
I mean like I know a lot of some people
like you know we live in Toronto and
trying to lie to film in New York and
all that and there's I guess work all
over the place but but I mean LA just
like the heart and soul of all of it and
it's just so much more convenient for
everything and that like all the deals
were made out here and it's just like
you know it's everyone's like in sync I
mean it is like a bubble but like it's
you know it's it's it's good to be part
of that bubble I think
you